ukrainian troops are trying to hold off
russian attacks in much of ukraine's
east the kremlin wants to capture the
whole of the industrial donbass region
but gains are smaller and coming slower
than expected
further south on the sea of azov a
handful of civilians has been allowed to
leave a steelworks in the besieged city
of mariopol
families of those still trapped in the
port town gathered in the capital kiev
so they would not be forgotten
the anguish is etched on their faces
these women fled mariupol but their
loved ones did not
now in ukraine's capital kyiv they are
pleading for the lives of their besieged
family members
one woman says she can't eat knowing
that her husband is starving
another issued this call to action
we as wives of the defenders express our
willingness to become human shields to
make a corridor to marry yupo to protect
an international delegation
we asked the un
we ask believers of all faiths we asked
the red cross and all of them to join
our march to marry you paul
we will become a human shield for the
delegation to help evacuate our husbands
they are here in the azov style steel
plant the final holdout in ukraine's
port city of marieupol
conditions are thought to be dire
slow the deputy commander of the azov
regiment ukraine's far-right nationalist
unit reported that 20 civilians were
safely evacuated russia says 25 people
were freed from the steel plant
ukraine's president has vowed to fight
for those still trapped inside
all the leaders of the free world know
what russia has done to mariupol
russia will be held to account for this
many world leaders are trying to help
save our heroic defenders of the city
this was discussed in great detail with
the u.n secretary general during his
visit to cuve
we're doing everything everything to
ensure that the evacuation mission for
mariupol is carried out
far from mariupol in ukraine's north
authorities say they've uncovered more
evidence of alleged russian atrocities
in bucha a town now synonymous with
claims of war crimes the bodies of three
more civilians were found
police say the men had been tortured and
bound and shot in the head
with many residents in butcher still
unaccounted for survivors in the scar
town know that more grim discoveries
could still be unearthed
and for more let's bring in dw
correspondent matthias billinger who is
now in ukraine's main port city of
odessa in the southeast mathias
ukraine's military says a russian
missile hit the runway in the airport of
odessa where you're at what else do you
know
yeah yesterday shortly after we arrived
we heard three loud explosions and uh
the runway has been hit by missiles it's
destroyed it cannot be used anymore no
people have suffered in these attacks uh
and uh the missiles that hit this runway
were fired from crimea um which is the
the territory that russia has annexed in
2014.
and you were just in the capital kiev
before coming to odessa what's the
situation like there
uh the kiev is is
now for for more than a month or for
about one month
no russian troops are near kiev anymore
so life uh is a little bit is returning
to the city the city is a little bit
more uh relaxed than it had been of
course when it was it was never besieged
but the troops were in some parts uh
they were very close to the to the city
borders and um now this has changed so
the situation is is
is uh it's not normal of course many
people have left the city it's pretty
empty a lot of shops are closed and a
lot there's a curfew and so on and so on
but it doesn't feel as
critical as before having said that kiev
like any other city in ukraine is still
a target for missile attacks and just a
few days ago there was a missile attack
while the u.n secretary general was
there so there is of course uh it is of
course a wartime capital
and just to to move on to mario paul
where of course those holdout fighters
are being besieged in the steel works uh
what else can you tell us about the
situation there
so uh the good news that we heard
yesterday is that about 20 people have
left we've just heard that
the steel works and uh that's uh 20
people out of an estimated 1000
civilians it's very difficult to leave
that place there has been heavy fighting
the site has been heavily bombarded and
you would need some kind of a ceasefire
to be able to leave and these ceasefires
are being negotiated with the help of
the un
but often they do not uh
they do not happen even if they have
been agreed to what we heard yesterday
from that commander of the azov
battalion is that it had been agreed to
have a ceasefire from the morning and
the civilians these 20 civilians could
leave in the evening so how it will go
for the other
several hundred civilians who are in
there we have no idea
okay dw's mathias billinger in odessa
thanks for that
russia's intensifying offensive in
ukraine's east and south has left the
country in need of weapons and fighters
across the country ordinary citizens
have joined the territorial defense
units a volunteer force our
correspondent yan philip schultz met a
mother and daughter who have taken up
arms together
for natalya and her daughter veronica
the last weeks have been a crash course
in weaponry
on the second day of the war natalia
enlisted in ukraine's territorial
defense forces
veronica soon followed
a few days later they were deployed as
volunteer fighters
like any mother i worry about my child
but she made her own decision and i
tried not to influence her
and of course it also makes me a little
proud that my daughter is accompanying
me
pictures of their everyday lives from
just three months ago show another world
natalia was a fashion designer her
daughter studied medicine
when the war began many of their family
and friends fled abroad it's a decision
both women can understand
but for them it wasn't an option
all my siblings are now abroad in italy
greece and canada
no one ever thought i'd be the one
staying in the country
i've always been a little bit of the
posh girl but i just told them
we'll see each other after we win
it's estimated that women make up around
10 of the ukrainian armed forces
men have physical advantages but women
are often mentally stronger says natalia
and both sexes are prepared to put their
lives on the line for their country
the comrades fighting in the east say
killing someone for the first time is
always hard
now i think maybe i can do it
you never know until you're actually in
that situation
despite their fears or what they might
face on the front line both are certain
that ukraine will win the war
let's have a look now at some of the
other stories related to the war in
ukraine
the u.s speaker of the house of
representatives nancy pelosi has met
with ukraine's president vladimir
zelinski in the capital kiev
pelosi is the highest ranking american
official to visit ukraine
video from ukrainian officials shows
talks with
the congressional delegation pelosi
praised ukraine's defense of freedom and
zielinski thanked the visitors for
america's support
hollywood actor angelina jolie has also
made a surprise visit to ukraine in the
western city of la vie she spoke to
people displaced by the war and children
wounded by a russian missile strike
surely is a special envoy for the united
nations refugee agency last month she
visited yemen where millions have also
been displaced by the war
american president joe biden has praised
journalists for their coverage of the
war in ukraine
biden was speaking at the white house
correspondents dinner an annual gala
that in the past two years was cancelled
due to the pandemic
biden said that a rising disinformation
has made press freedom more important
than ever
[Applause]
new footage from the ukrainian village
of demeudev has revealed the damage
caused by a tactical flood on day two of
the war the village was intentionally
flooded to stop the advance of russian
soldiers ukraine's army has been
strategically destroying infrastructure
around the country to thwart their enemy